President Trump is expected to sign his
new tariff plan as soon as today he's
calling for a 25% tariff on imported
steel and 10% for aluminum more than 100
congressional Republicans oppose the
plan Nebraska senator Ben Sasse is one
of those against the plan calling the
tariffs a massive tax increase on
American families and he says you'd
expect a policy this bad from a leftist
administration he joins us now from
Capitol Hill for an interview you'll
only see on CBS this morning senator
good morning them John them's fightin
words so what are you gonna do other
than fight is there anything you can do
to get in the way of what the
president's trying to do here well for
decades the Congress has punted lots and
lots of its responsibilities and
authorities to the executive branch and
regardless of whether you're Republican
or Democrat that's a bad idea for public
deliberation because right now we don't
have a very clear understanding and in
the country about what's happening in
our economy these tariffs are a terrible
idea
but they're not just a terrible idea
this week or this month but they're a
terrible idea because it doesn't make
sense of where we are in economic
history tariffs always hurt us
ultimately nobody ever wins a trade war
both sides lose a trade war trade is
indisputably good for America it's good
for consumers on both sides of every
trading relationship and all of our
trade deals have been on net good for
America in terms of job creation and a
lot of the public doesn't understand
that and so we need do a lot better job
of explaining what actually happens when
there's more trade we need more trade
America wins when there is okay then how
do you explain a trade deficit of nearly
a billion dollars eight hundred million
dollars President Trump tweeting
yesterday that the US has lost 55
thousand factories six million
manufacturing jobs and has this huge
trade deficit isn't it time for there to
be something done about this yes so
let's back up because a lot of times
trade deficits on a bilateral basis or
just completely misunderstood I have a
trade deficit with the grocery store
they supply a whole bunch of really good
stuff that I want and I give them my
money and that circulates back into the
economy here's what actually happens
when you have more trade when
have more trade it means that American
families are buying more high quality or
low-cost or usually both stuff from some
trading partner on the other side of a
border what happens in the u.s. is when
there's more trade we have more export
markets Nebraska where I live is the
most productive farmland in the history
of the world
we feed the world and our economy is
fundamentally dependent upon the fact
that we produce better and higher
quality stuff than any other farmers in
the world and so we need more markets to
sell it to than just the US so let's
look at steel in particular when you
raise tariffs on steel 320 million
American consumers lose because
everybody who went to the store last
night and buying something for their
kids or for their household that they
need there were metal products in it and
when you have tariffs you raise prices
on steel and all 320 million American
consumers lose but at the level of
production even before you get to
retaliation and let's be clear if the
president goes through with this it will
kill American jobs there will be
retaliation and specific American
families and producers and workers are
gonna lose but even before you get to
retaliation if you just look at steel
this plan will kill steel jobs in
America why how could that be it sounds
like you'd be doing this because you're
trying to help steel workers there are a
hundred and forty thousand production
steel mill workers in America there are
more than 5 million factory workers in
America that work at factories that use
steel as a primary input when you raise
the price of steel those factory workers
are gonna lose jobs there are going to
be some of those hundred and forty
thousand steel production workers that
will benefit there'll be lots more of
the five million steel workers that use
them as inputs that are going to suffer
we need to start telling the American
people the truth about what's happening
in big factory jobs and the analog is
agriculture in nineteen hundred more
than forty percent of Americans worked
on farms a hundred years later less than
two percent and yet we produce more
stuff that's what's happening in
industrial factory jobs right now we
have rapidly declining numbers of people
working in industrial jobs but we have
more total output we need to start
developing our technology it's very
clear to all of us listening how much
you love your state and how much you're
against this proposal but back to John's
original question what can you do what
are you going to do about
yeah I mean I'm gonna talk to you and
I'm going to talk to the American people
because the president has the power to
do this under current law it's stupid
policy but he has the authority there's
a there's a big fight happening inside
the administration right now because
most senior people in the White House
know that this is a really dumb policy
and the American people have forgotten
workers of even the Rust Belt states
they don't want to be drafted and be
casualties in a stupid trade war and so
there are a bunch of people inside the
administration trying to talk the
president out of this but you can see
the mixed messages coming out of the
administration when we say we're doing
this to target China and you know who
loses most Canada one of our fundamental
partners there are main in there the
main exporter of steel to the US senator
you talk about the organization inside
the White House you used to repair
organizations for a living assess the
organization inside the White House
right now so it's it's a tough place to
work and there are a lot of really good
people there and the President does
deserve credit for a lot of good people
he's put in this administration somebody
like Don Magan who's helping him pick
judges doing a phenomenal job a lot of
the regular triage and a lot of them are
leaving it's it's a chaotic place Gail
I'm not gonna argue with you about that
and ultimately this White House is a
reflection of this president and he said
that he likes chaos I don't think that's
really a great way to run an
organization but I saved most of my
counsel on that topic for the president
in private we actually have a
surprisingly good relationship we
wrestle a lot in private before I'm out
here criticizing him in public but in
the trade war that we're talking about
today it's gonna hurt Americans it's
gonna hurt American families and it's
gonna cost us jobs and I hope the
president walks back from the brink okay
see if he's listening to you thank you
very much senators house for taking your
time this morning